on the first anniversary of the assault
on the capital president biden blamed
former president trump for that deadly
attack many members of congress who were
besieged that day returned to the
capitol last night holding a vigil on
the steps where trump supporters first
confronted police officers one more of
those officers sued mr trump yesterday
accusing him of stoking the violence
chris van cleave covered the ride one
year ago this morning he's on capitol
hill chris good morning
good morning you know for people that
were at the capitol one year ago january
6 2022 really was a day of reflection
and you heard it from lawmakers and
staff sharing their memories and their
close calls but the partisan divide here
in washington was on display as many
republicans were absent from the capitol
entirely and most did not participate in
yesterday's events
a moment of silence thursday night on
capitol hill as a solemn day of
remembrances came to an end on the
anniversary of the january 6th deadly
attack on the capitol this was an armed
insurrection speaking to the nation
president biden did not use president
trump's name but he was clear he
believes the former president bears the
blame for the capital attack a president
had not just lost an election
he tried to prevent the peaceful
transfer of power
as a violent mob breached the capitol
and while some lawmakers reflected on
their experiences that day i'm standing
here before you today
because capitol police saved my life
former vice president dick cheney joined
his daughter congressman liz cheney as
the lone republicans on the house floor
leadership that resembles any of the
folks i knew when i was here virginia
congresswoman cheney is one of two
republicans serving on the house select
committee investigating january 6 and
the president's actions that day the
committee is looking at that looking at
whether what he did
constitutes
that kind of a crime but certainly it's
dereliction of duty democrat jamie
raskin says former vice president mike
pence is cooperating with the committee
i don't think
he's been asked to testify quite yet and
so we'll see though there's been an
effort by some on the right to rewrite
what happened one year ago for capitol
police lieutenant ted hopkins who helped
lead the effort to retake the building
the memories are clear americans
attacked us they they attacked the
police
they attacked the capital and in doing
so really attacked democracy it was
violent and
everything you see all the footage you
see is nothing but violence
any any attempt to say it was anything
other than that is a bit delusional
and we're also learning new details
about the whereabouts of then vice
president-elect harris she was at the
capitol in the morning she left she was
at the dnc headquarters not far from the
capitol building in the early afternoon
on the sixth when she was rushed out of
the building about the same time as a
pipe bomb was found outside the suspect
responsible is still being sought by the
fbi as for former president trump he
released multiple statements yesterday
he continued to spread baseless claims
of election fraud and told his
supporters to quote never give up gail
all right thank you very much chris